is the new normal it's when we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives today we are
focusing on the airline industries
struggle to bounce back so take a look
at this
on july 13th last year 2.6 million
travelers went through tsa checkpoints
on the same day this year that total had
plunged to less than 700 thousand
the airlines in short are reeling delta
suffered its worst losses in more than a
decade
and its ceo does not expect business
travel to return to 2019 levels
southwest ceo says they will have to cut
staff
if the number of passengers does not
triple and that seems unlikely
cbs news senior travel advisor peter
greenberg joins us peter good morning so
the airlines they've gotten billions of
dollars in relief
funding but they are facing serious
trouble and i think it calls into
question
what air travel will look like and feel
like even after we're back to something
like a
normal what's the future hold for them
well the numbers are not lying here in
fact they're pretty bad
uh delta's loss was in the last quarter
was 5.7 billion dollars let me break
that out for you
that's losing 27 million dollars a day
now that's better than their loss back
in march which was a hundred million
dollars a day
and to break that out even further 30
million of those dollars was just for
refunds being issued to passengers
for canceled flights so you've got delta
basically trying to do
voluntary furloughs to cut the number of
their staff 17 000 members of their
organization already signed up for it
you mentioned southwest airlines today
is the deadline for their employees to
opt in or out
of a voluntary furlough period and
american airlines has already said
they think they have 8 000 flight
attendants too many the real key here
tony is looking at october 1st because
that's the day
that the provisions of the federal
bailout of the airlines which really
require them to fly
all of their staff on payroll until that
day expire
and that's when you're going to see
these airlines get very small yeah so
part of the reason why
there aren't a lot of passengers on
airlines is because there's not a lot
going on when you travel you know
museums are closed concerts are not
happening
the other reason is even if you have
somewhere to go you may not feel
comfortable in the cabin of an airplane
it feels anyway like a very tight space
where the virus could spread easily is
that true in reality
well there's some studies that say
that's true however the actual
you know dimensions of an airline cabin
and social distancing are sort of
mutually exclusive
if you take a look at a window seat and
an aisle seat separation with nobody in
that middle seat
the separation's only 22 inches that's
not six feet not to mention the guy
behind you 14 inches away
who basically just sneezed on the other
hand they do have uh
hospital grade filters in many
particularly the newer models which
circulate the air very quickly so that
is one
benefit we can point to when could this
return to some sort of normal what is
your projection for it and as it returns
is there a silver lining for anybody
particularly people who have
a mountain of miles or benefits or
credit card kind of rewards
that now they have no way to spend
well business travel is basically
flatlined and will stay in coma until
march or april
with the lack of a vaccine or
therapeutics but there is a silver
lining here and that is if you're
sitting on a lot of frequent flyer miles
here's the irony of it
six months ago the planes were full the
airlines were reluctant to give anybody
a frequent flyer award
because they didn't want to displace
your revenue passenger now they got
nothing but seats
so if you're looking at november
december january travel
usually very high a seasonal travel time
you know what
redeem those miles now first of all the
redemption levels have been lowered in
many cases and the airlines are going to
give you those seats
that's good news there you know peter
before we go i do want to ask you why
are there so many different approaches
here to how the airlines
treat passengers some are selling the
middle seat some are leaving it open to
encourage distancing it seems like just
as
we have many states with different
policies we have many airlines with
different policies
the reason for that is the federal
government has not made it a mandate
there's no federal air regulation that's
been put into place by the faa
and last but not least you know delta
airlines is now reporting
that the number one reason why people
are booking their airline is because
they've agreed to block the middle seat
through the end of september
there you go it all comes back to
federal leadership peter greenberg thank
you very much